let's go and take a call from Skype
caller who is calling in via Skype
please tell us who you are and what's on
your mind hi can you hear me we can hear
you oh hi my name is Ricky I'm calling
from the United Arab Emirates my phone
wasn't working so I called via Skype
very good my question my question is
would you support a woman's right to
choose an abortion even if it's for you
know terrible reasons for example would
you be okay with a woman wanting the
race of her baby tested hypothetically
if if it was ambiguous who their father
was and wanna get aborted if the baby
was black because at first I was
thinking there's no reason to allow an
abortion because she's still fine with a
baby being inside or she's just
concerned about the cosmetics but you
know I'm also less offended about a
woman choosing to abort a baby with Down
syndrome for example so do you think
it's inconsistent to not support women
aborting babies based on race sir so
there's a couple different things here
one is whether the technology would
allow doing what it is that you're that
you're looking to do and then a second
time medically it would let's say it
would right so let's say it would for a
second you're asking about whether it
should be allowed legally the it sounds
horrible to say hey listen let's allow
women first of all how likely is it it's
it's not very common that a woman would
be pregnant and have no idea what the
race of the baby inside of her even is
right so let we have to sort of sis
believe even to address this question
you agree with that yeah yeah okay the
problem with saying it's illegal to ask
- for a woman to abort a baby based on
race preferences is that you don't have
to ask women in order to know that you
need to demand a reason for the abortion
and that's just not the way it works if
you support a right to choose what
matters is are you you know procuring a
safe and legal abortion based on the law
that's they're based on restrictions in
terms of when in the pregnancy you
either are or aren't allowed to seek an
abortion and that's it so in order to do
what you're saying you need to have a
system where the provider asks what the
reason is and that's hugely problematic
and it's not something that's part of
the law right now yeah would be pretty
difficult to all
so ensure that the reason was valid as
well absolutely yes so I think that it's
an unanswerable question because there
are no reasonable circumstances in which
anybody would ever know that of people
who are seeking abortions right don't
always just make up a reason you could
always lie - right what would the point
be exactly that you can always my point
but you know I get if it could be
somehow be proven and we could ask
another short question sure God do you
think Mike Pence would be a better
president than Trump uh well I think
that he would be less scandalous but he
would be far more effective in terms of
pushing and authoritarian you know
ideological right-wing agenda I've
talked about that before though so check
out some of my guys ok great to hear
from the UAE what's it like living there
by the way anyway um it's well by the
way I was the guy who posted on reddit
about your hair the other day back then
so about 5,000 people posted online
about my hair because it was so crazy so
I don't know offhand which one you were
but um I posted the picture of your hair
from a couple years ago oh okay got it
yeah yeah helmet hair got it yeah I'm
pretty good in Dubai I'm actually an
American like Indian ethnically but yeah
it's grating - bye you're an American
that's interesting what what ethnicity
is there I know I'm sorry did I say
ethnically market I mean I met Nick Lee
an Indian but I have an American
citizenship like I said I'm living in as
an expat ytube I gotcha as a student all
right and are you hold on are you
allowed to drink alcohol there yeah it's
very liberal you're actually very little
they're not very they're not very kind
to the locals if they drink alcohol or
stuff but expats are basically not
subject to this okay good what I'm
underaged anyways oh you say you're not
drinking anyway of course right why
would I ever again apply that alright
thank you so much for the call very very
much appreciate it let's take a break
we'll be back after this